we've involved a range of Specialists
both locally regionally and nationally
the investigation has not wanted at any
stage for experts who are the best in
their field available to law enforcement
in the UK
I would emphasize that it Remains the
case there is no evidence to to indicate
a criminal aspect or third-party
involvement in Nicholas disappearance
however the the officers involved in the
investigation
are the same experienced Specialists and
many senior officers
who are concerned with the investigation
of the most serious and complex crimes
that is the importance and focus we have
given to the investigation to find
Nicola
to give you some figures to back up some
of what I've described
we visited more than 300 premises
spoken to almost 300 people and received
around about 1 500 pieces of information
into the inquiry
in terms of the physical searches both
water-based and on land
we've used specialist resources from
both police
a range of other agencies and I'm
grateful to those other agencies who've
supported us
and in police assets that's included the
Northwest underwater search units
police drones horses dogs and the police
helicopter
we continue to search extensively the
river wire
and surrounding area Downstream and out
into the sea towards the estuary
we've consulted with national experts in
their field including environmental
Untitled experts
and we're carrying out an extensor have
carried out an extensive land search
surrounding the river including some
properties around the area where Nicola
went missing